[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's a prof
hello
that was a synchronized attempt yes
yes
well don't bother about the other
questions let's leave that out i think
you've got something interesting that
you would like to mention
before we start before we start yes
we received a letter
from
new zealand
and it's a very sweet letter
and let me open it
it's handwritten and it's got some
numbers and things on the top
and so i just want to show this letter
because
firstly i want to thank the person who
wrote it and may the lord
bless him richly
or her i don't have a name
because i assume there was something
else in this envelope
it's been pasted closed
and whatever else was in here is no
longer in there
because if you send something
with a financial contribution to south
africa
i don't know it seems that the people
who handle the post have x-ray eyes
they are experts
so we didn't receive it and we don't
know who it's from
so we just want to say thank you
and
i hope that the contribution that was in
there if there was one in there
that it will
serve a good cause in the end in spite
of the circumstances yeah well maybe we
can just ask then again we've mentioned
it to a few people that want to send us
things via the post
it's
the chances of it arriving
and getting into our hands is very slim
yes i've just heard of a parcel that was
sent to me
and it was sent about
probably seven months ago
and
they closed our post office yeah
they just closed it
i got a notice that there was a parcel
but there was no way to retrieve it
and now i heard after seven months that
they found the parcel
and it's at another post office yeah
so
it's it's a nightmare if you said
something via the post it's either by
the courier yes or electronically or
else
whatever happened to this one will
happen to those as well
so that's just
a quick
a quick sideline so let's open with a
word of prayer because we've got a very
important discussion today
our heavenly father
we thank you that we still have the
opportunity to do these discussions and
we ask that you bless the discussion and
also the viewers and thank you for
people
that go out of their way
to do your will
we ask that you all bless us all in
jesus name amen amen
button i see we have a rather
lengthy
title here it's more like a description
isn't it yes actually
this is what the whole session will be
about so it's good versus evil light
versus darkness church and state salt
and light the great awakening
leading to the rewriting of the
constitution question mark double blind
yes i just want to mention maybe those
titles in the beginning the good versus
evil light versus darkness church and
state
like salt and light there's great
awakening there's a lot of sounds that's
being made
by the christian world
so that is the kind of lingo
that is being branded around
and
it's very interesting and will it lead
to the rewriting of the constitution
and what is this double-blind thing we
have to look at all of it
because if you study your bible martin
then you will know
[Music]
that
we are not dealing
with straight up and down things what
you see is never what you get we are
leading with dealing with deception
it was a deceiver
it was a liar from the beginning
so what can you expect deception and
lies exactly and that's exactly what
jesus warned us
against yes and so often if you if you
speak about deception and lies then
people will
want to question that and put it into
all kinds of categories but that's what
the bible says will happen so let's look
at this
also in the light of double blind
so we'll go across some
news items
and some videos
and we'll see how this fits into the
prophetic picture because that's always
our aim right everything that happens
how does it fit into the prophetic
picture because once again
when you look at this
it can look very good from a christian
perspective yes but that's where you
have to be careful to see if it's not
taking you in a direction that the bible
don't doesn't want you to go in correct
all right and these are all current that
we're talking about this is what's
happening in the world today
and we need just to keep up to date so
our usual style is we will look at
spiritual aspects and then we'll go into
current events and then we'll look at
the spiritual aspects because we do not
want them to become divorced from each
other
we don't want to
disintegrate into a news channel we want
to be a prophetic based
organization and that's what our our
studies are about
so trump tied conservatives of 15 states
away from an unprecedented rewrite of
the constitution
it's interesting that they say trump
tied yeah but you know you can take that
name trump and you can take it out and
you can replace it with anything else of
a similar
context
but this is what they're talking about
so with congress's initiative the u.s
constitution has been amended 27 times
but never has the core american document
be amended through a state-led process
the second track that the founders
created under the article 5 of the
constitution
the conservatives are frustrated by
democrats control of washington
and even when republicans are in charge
the growing size of government the
convention of the state's movement
is just one of the organizations pushing
for such a convention
but it's a perhaps the best funded and
has made the most recent progress
and it has ties to the former president
donald trump's orbit such as former
republican senator rick santorum
now about
a few years ago i think it was in
i have a lecture where i showed that
rick santorum was very anti the
separation of church and state he was a
presidential candidate at that stage
there is also john eastman the
conservative legal scholar who supported
trump's effort to overturn the election
and five states wisconsin
south carolina nebraska oklahoma and
west virginia have passed the
organization's pro-convention resolution
in the past two years
someone there's progress right yeah it's
actually picking up it's picking up
with republicans poised for a wave
election in november more gop-controlled
states could join the pro-convention
resolution crowd if that happens well
then the constitution can be amended but
we have to ask ourselves
what is it they want to amend and why
yes
surely it's not just about gun control
no definitely not and not only about
this or that there's specific
reasons and those reasons are biblical
so we have to look at the role players
and we have to look at the mindset of
the role players then we can understand
where they're heading maybe i might just
clarify
by meaning that those changes are
biblical i don't mean that it's correct
i mean that the bible
has in it
prophecies that say that this can happen
yes
because whenever you deal with something
like that the first thing that
becomes
a central talking point is freedom of
choice
here's an article from fox news states
one step closer in uphill unconventional
approach to amend the constitution
to limit federal government power
now this sounds very nice there's a huge
bureaucracy you want to slim it down
and you need a
change in the constitution in order to
do that
so they say
but is that really
what is happening or is this just the
carrot
i believe it's just the carrot
a state senator calling for
constitutional amendment said that
overreach on the part of federal
government
has forced states to attend reform
in a way never accomplished before
the nebraska legislature passed a
resolution in january 28 calling on
states to begin the formal process to
pass constitutional amendments
that would limit the federal
government's spending and jurisdiction
as well as set term limits for members
of congress
it takes 34 states to call the
convention and 38 states are needed to
ratify an amendment
nebraska was the 17th state marking the
halfway point to pass such a resolution
since the effort started in 2013.
wisconsin passed one the week prior the
resolution has passed one chamber in
eight states and legislation is pending
in 15 more state legislatures
a convention of states under article 5
has never been called amendments instead
have been proposed through congress
only 27 have been added since the
constitution was adopted so this is
basically the same
just gives a little bit more detail
but we need more than one witness so two
or three witnesses is is a good thing
now let's look at some of the role
players
one of the role players is rick santorum
and here's an article from the august
the 1st of 2022
and he wants the states to throw a live
piece of ammo at washington with a
constitutional convention
so former senator rick santorum wants
republican state lawmakers
to throw a grenade at washington dc and
pull the pin with the first of its kind
constitutional convention
he's pushing
for a rapid change we need to know
what's behind it remember this is a
former presidential candidate
audio of santorum's appearance at the
american legislative exchange council
december 2021 policy
summit obtained by the left-leaning
watchdog group the center for media and
democracy and shared with insider reveal
how he sells a convention to state
lawmakers
quote
one more state and then you take this
grenade and you pull the pin he told a
crowd of assembled lawmakers
you've got a last piece of ammo in your
hands 34 states and if every republican
legislature votes for this we have a
constitutional convention
santorum said a convention would reign
in the deep state
now we've had so many
talks about the deep state and the swamp
and so many events taking place like the
raiding of the dwellings of donald trump
and the
encroachment on certain areas where
people think that they should be left
alone and in peace
and every time it is the deep state the
deep state
but we know there's someone behind the
deep state because the bible tells us
who the problem is right
and then he assured the assembled
lawmakers that the gop's interests would
dominate a one-state one vote for the
same reason
that rural conservative areas have an
outside influence in electoral college
and the pennsylvania legislature
so
he is propagating behind the scenes
here's an article from february 2012
when he was a presidential candidate
and he said
that the speech that jfk gave
makes me want to throw up
so perhaps we should just remind the
viewers
and
i don't know it verbatim but i know the
essence of it
he said i believe in an america
where no
pope or people prelate
will dictate to the government or the
president what he should do and i
believe in america where no protestant
prelate will tell the people how to vote
because
the separation of church and state has
to be absolute that's the essence of
what he said
and rick santorum said that when he
listens to that he wants to throw up
because he's of this old catholic school
it's interesting that jfk was a catholic
too
but he's of this school
where he believes that the church wields
the sword the spiritual sword
and that the secular sword is subject to
the spiritual soul
and once you have that situation then
the church dictates
morality to the state and the state's
duty is to implement it that's what
happened in the middle ages
and that's why the blood flowed for eons
and millions and millions of people died
and were tortured
so when the constitution was set up
that it was it was necessary to prevent
that from ever happening happening again
so they wanted to prevent the bloodshed
that took place in europe from ever
entering the shores of the united states
of america
but the bible says they will speak like
a dragon yes
and the dragon is the one who gave the
power unto the beast
and the beast is he's lackey
does what the dragon wants and the
dragon is the old serpent the devil
so the devil
wants to force you to do his will it's
called coercion
that's why if anything months should
make you throw up it's any form of
coercion yes particularly when the
coercion comes from a church yes no
matter what church that exactly so this
just shows you what the real reason is
that they want to change the
constitution correct
so let's read what they said then
republican presidential candidate rick
santorum says the notion of religion not
playing role in politics makes me want
to throw up
he said more than that he said that
the fact that a pope or a protestant may
not dictate to the state
makes him want to throw up
to say that people of faith have no role
in the public square
you see this is again a total distortion
of course everybody has a role in the
public sphere
if you if you vote you have a role in
the public sphere
if you
present an opinion
then you have a role in the public
sphere
when you preach a sermon you have a role
in the public sphere someone basically
it's when they legislate their morality
[Music]
that there is the potential for a
problem
particularly if that morality clashes
with the morality of the bible
what kind of country do we live in
where only people of non-faith can come
in the public square and make their case
that makes me throw up and that should
make every american throw up santerum
said
on abc this week
again that is a distortion
because there's a vast difference of
saying your say in the public square and
legislating morality big difference yes
the former pennsylvania senator was
referring to john f kaye's
famous 1960 speech
that argued religion should be separate
from politics i don't believe in an
america where the separation between
church and state is absolute he said so
this is just to show his mindset his
opinion yeah it's totally opposite of
what jfk said but it's also distorting
what he said yes
by the way
was jfk in the public square yes
so this just shows that his argument is
not relevant right
republicans next big play is to scare
the hell out of washington by rewriting
the constitution and they're willing to
play
the long game to win this comes from the
business insider
of this year we don't have to read at
all because we've had the background
let's just read the highlighted portion
rob nettleson a constitutional scholar
and senior fellow at the independence
institute who closely studies article 5
of the constitution
predicted to insider there's a 50 chance
that the united states will witness a
constitutional convention in the next
five years
whether it happens he said is highly
dependent on republican success winning
state legislatures during the 2022
midterm elections
now this is just conjecture it might
happen it might not happen
but if it happens
it will be quite substantial
repercussions yes because we'll see what
the mindset is why they want to change
it now what's interesting up until now
there's always been this balance of
power
and one party could never actually do
whatever it wanted to do because either
they had a majority
in congress but they didn't have a
majority in the senate or the other way
around
or some people were swayed there was
never an absolute majority in order to
do whatever you wanted to do
so what if the pendulum swings martin
yes
what if people become so fed up with
liberalism what if you open the
floodgates
so that people should become fed up
and you bring about the pendulum swing
then this could be a distinct
possibility i think if you just
go according to what they stated there
in the last two years
all those states that already joined him
it's telling you that there might be
people that's getting fed up yes they're
getting fed up
well here's a video of someone who's
also standing for the senate
so let's have a look what they have to
say just to give us an idea of current
thinking
i do not believe
in separation of church and state there
is no such thing the founders of this
country the founding fathers they did
not believe in separation at church and
state when you read the united states
constitution nowhere in the united
states constitution do you read about
separation of church and state it does
not exist
when i started this campaign
i made a decision
and the decision i made was rather than
running my campaign through traditional
republican party groups
i was going to run my campaign through
churches
the reason is
we're not going to save this country
in political offices
we're not going to save this country in
big corporate office towers
we're going to save this country in
churches in barns and kitchen tables
throughout the state and throughout this
country
the judeo-christian bedrock of america
is the foundation of this country
america was founded on judeo-christian
values
not on muslim values
not on atheism but on judeo-christian
values
there's so many
factors that separate that
judeo-christian belief set from these
other belief sets like islam and atheism
and one of the main differentiating
factors
is our belief
in good over evil and our willingness to
fight for good over evil
well there was a rousing speech
good over evil
judea christian culture
now
yes we have roots in the old testament
let's say that is judea
and we have roots in the new testament
let's say that is christian culture
when you mix the two you have a certain
dichotomy you have a little problem yeah
because according to the new testament
the old testament is the gospel in type
and the new testament is the gospel in
antitype
it is the fulfillment of
the prophecies and the promises
now if you take those two groups
and you join them together
one accepts jesus christ as the messiah
the other one does not one keeps the
seventh day sabbath the other does not
keeps the first day sabbath
so even within that group you have a
dichotomy
what can make two opposites
come together a common goal ah
pilate and herod
were enemies
but when it came to
the
crucifixion of jesus
they combined their voices and from that
day forth they were friends
now this is a very serious issue
if you combine two opposites
in order to achieve a goal
that goal might actually
not lead you in the right direction
i almost think it most certainly won't
okay
so although the speech sounds noble
and he says that the solution lies in
the churches
and in the private discussions rather
than in government
and this is the forerunner of speaking
like a dragon yes and there's another
thing that they also said are willing to
fight for it
this fight
is not the biblical fight
with fight the good fight
this fight means actual
actually maybe getting into conflict
all right
and this this fight
will lead to coercion
it will it has to
the the civil war the first civil war of
the american that was also a religious
fight okay
he talked about judeo-christian culture
let's say they start legislating the
sabbath issue
which is of course one of their favorite
topics
isn't there a dichotomy there
will one of them have to
surrender their opinion for the sake of
the common so-called good
and what if that opinion is contrary to
the bible that's where it will end
okay
you know we can talk about all of these
things
until we are blue in the face
but just to set the stage where are we
heading
at the commonwealth games
they brought out this mechanical bull
with all the ritualism of baal worship
and there were so many programs and so
many
from the religious side
that were appalled at what was happening
because it was
obviously a religious
symbolic
enactment
and then there was a woman riding the
beast as well which is of course the
symbol of
the ten horns it's europe
because that's one of the emblems the
woman riding the beast and you will find
it
at the european parliament there'll be
statues of this now we've spoken about
all these things in the past
but such a blatant
worship
activity
has seldom been seen and so people think
where is the world heading
that the evil is actually
taken over
and this is what we have to deal with
now so now they think
and you see sometimes people can
misinterpret what we're saying here yeah
we're not saying this is good no
you must see what the what's behind this
this is bigger than just this that's
coming out because
now they you would have sympathy for a
movement to get up to
get rid of this correct
just on that point martin some people
say
we we speak euphemistically
we should come straight out and say it
exactly how it is sometimes it's not
wise to do that
and jesus also didn't do it he spoke in
parables now the pharisees knew that he
spoke this parable against them but
there was nothing they could do because
he didn't directly
address him but he addressed the problem
yes and he opened the debate
so sometimes you have to be a little bit
euphemistic now we could also make this
a soapbox
and rant and rave about the evil that is
going on in the world this is just a
symptom of a much greater evil
we know this is all there and so this is
part of a deception yes
so here we see how
some people portrayed it
so they referred to it as worshiping the
beast written by the harlot
probably correct
right or this one a massive red herring
obvious demonic imagery to fuel the
great awakening deception
that's a little bit more
conspiracy theory aligned
but the bible is the greatest conspiracy
theory ever written
and
yes
where is this leading to and why are
they so
blatant
because
this can create a pendulum swing that's
now whether they do it knowingly or
whether they do it unknowingly
is irrelevant
who is the instigator the one that
affects the mind behind the scenes
the serpent the serpent the dragon
dragon
now
personally i think if you put something
like this together like this performance
that they had we could go into into
detail
there are many many videos about it i
don't think we have to
then i would say
they knew exactly what they were doing
exactly
you see there was actually a double
blind in the performance as well because
the commentators
were saying this
mechanical bull
was the stock market
and how in in the
industrial revolution you see so the
whole theme was around that
but then the double blind is it's
obvious that this was as well
bale worship it was an act of worship
because they knelt down they took
praying positions etc etc so yes this
was definitely something that would rile
up the evangelical world and bring them
to boiling point
that's where it comes in now so there's
another deception because that's also
done on purpose yes and so what will be
the result i mean you always have to
think something through cause effect
consequences what will be the result
there will be a backlash
and people will say this has gone
far enough it's time to take the reins
of power
is that a possibility yes
okay
so let's have a few religious opinions
on this just to set the stage and let's
see what they say
the scripture tells us that in the last
days that there will be strong delusion
which means that all the ancient
deceptions and the ancient idolatry that
brought so much destruction upon the
ancient world is going to be repackaged
and it's going to be brought back and
the enemy is doing that today setting up
the world for the acceptance of that
person that the scripture calls the man
of sin
and also calls the antichrist what
happened in birmingham england is really
telling because we are living in that
time when the adversary is trying to
bring back baal worship what happened in
birmingham england was really nothing
more than an ancient ceremony that once
again looked at the bull as a symbol of
all the idolatrous practices and pagan
beliefs that are now destroying the
world all of us now are in danger and
there is not one person that is walking
in america right now that is not under
threat we're being threatened by a
intrusive government we're being
threatened by socialism communism and
marxism and especially globalism and
what is being done is that this thing
called wokism is really repackaged veil
worship so almost three years ago there
was something that took place where the
arch of baal was taken around the world
and wherever the arch of baal was placed
and all the capitals of the nations of
europe and here in our own nation it was
followed by a tremendous pandemic and
now the commonwealth gains have come out
and they are celebrating the calf again
like it was in ancient egypt like it was
in babylon and like it was in ancient
israel but god countered baal worship by
raising up the prophet elijah to contest
against the prophets of baal and we are
going to see a manifestation of god's
power on his people on the redeemed
bloodwash church in these last days that
will indeed bring the forces of darkness
to a standstill just before jesus comes
the spirit and the power of elijah is
coming back on a glorious church before
the rapture takes place and that we
might experience a final revival and a
last day harvest
martin my heart goes out to the man
but
there was a lot of confusion
in what he had to say
he made a reference to the antichrist
to them of course it is an individual
who's going to come
he's already here he's got full control
of everything
and he's alive and well and sitting in
rome and he was actually behind that you
see
with the serpent's help
he was the one instigating that old
thing he's his army
of knights of malta of jesuits and
whatever
are probably deeply involved in anything
that happens of this nature because he's
cushioned himself
he no longer is the antichrist and
therefore he can do whatever he likes
and be the hero at the same time that's
true the focus has been taken away all
right so that's the first great
deception then they're waiting for the
rapture and they want to harvest for the
rapture and so they want to take back
the power and then you have the kingdom
people that want to set up the kingdom
of god
on this earth etc etc so there's so much
confusion in that
but the passion
the anger
something has to be done and it has to
be done right now we have to take the
power back
because this is going to destroy us now
in no way are we saying that we think it
was good what those people did no
but it's leading us somewhere it's
leading towards biblical
fulfillment correct
so
let's take this from a games aspect into
the political realm
and see what the commentators are saying
about
church and state
and what will be the incentive to drive
humanity in that direction
one of the strangest things about
january the 6th for a lot of americans
was how many people in the pro-trump
crowd advertised their religious faith
flags that read jesus is my savior trump
is my president some people literally
carried crosses to the capitol and led
prayer groups on that day the religious
right has been around for a long time
but this kind of political expression of
religion one not separate from but
intimately connected to government
has grown increasingly common lately
we need to be the party of nationalism
and i'm a christian and i say it
probably we should be christian
nationalists as long as we are confident
in united the tyrants we are fighting
do not stand a chance
because we are americans and americans
kneel to god and god alone
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government is not
supposed to direct the church that is
not how our founding fathers intended it
and i'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk that's not in the
constitution it was in a stinking letter
and it means nothing like what they say
it does
but what exactly is christian
nationalism
according to christianity today it is a
mass movement that believes the american
nation is defined by being christian and
the government should keep it that way
some of these faithful are even building
patriot churches where parishioners pray
that quote communism and socialism and
transgenderism and homosexuality and
abortion will not have their way in this
land and they're getting elevated in
republican politics like doug mastriano
the gop nominee for pennsylvania
governor now masteriano is taking heat
for his close relationship with andrew
torba the ceo of the right-wing social
media site gav who this week renewed his
calls for an exclusively christian
nationalist conservative movement
so
no we don't want people who are atheists
we don't want people who are jewish this
is an explicitly christian movement
because this is an explicitly christian
country now we're not saying that uh you
know we're gonna deport all these people
or whatever you're free to stay here
right you're not gonna be forced to
convert or anything like this but you're
going to enjoy
the fruits of living in a christian
society under christian laws
you're going to live in a christian
society under christian
laws
martin
is that the church dictating to the
state 100
is that an image to the bees yes
that's what the beast was right that's
exactly what it is it's a state
um
religious conglomerate correct the
church dictating to the state and
enforcing
the church's
dictates all right so now we've had an
era of extreme liberalism
we've had a number of political
movements in the united states of
america and not only there but basically
worldwide
where
the restraints have been removed
and everything that is considered
non-biblical
has been enforced basically by
legislation
and now we're getting a backlash
the pendulum is going to swing
and many of the issues that are being
addressed in themselves are not bad
issues no that's exactly
where
take for instance just the past few
episodes that we had to clarify on which
side we are because this is the same
thing on what soapbox are you going to
stand
there are many soapboxes to choose from
the issue is
whose authority
are you going to be subjected to to say
christian that's what they're saying
christian morality christian authority
you're welcome to stay but you're going
to be under christian laws
whose laws are those going to be
the papacy pay pal laws yes and when
there are papal laws they are antichrist
laws because they're contrary to the
bible
there lies the double blind deception
one of the titles that we had martin was
salt and light
so these are all movements that are
taking place yes they've got the
jehu vs jezebel spirit movement it's
linked to the sultan light movement and
that's again linked to the great
awakening all of this religious
talk and so eventually what if you marry
the world economic forum ideology with
this christian movement wouldn't that be
a
rather interesting rollercoaster yes
because on the world economic forum
you've got the site of
climate change for the same
reason that you've got on this side
this whole awakening and on the one hand
you're decrying these organizations as
communist and deep state and what have
you and on the other hand you're going
to embrace them if there's something
that you can agree with and they will be
a common one there has to be a common
factor i wonder what that is going to be
but let's listen to the christian point
of view
that you vote for sherry clements she is
going to do everything she can to be
salt and light in this arena and try to
get this district on the right track
christians have have always been
involved as salt and light influence in
government in some of our most critical
hours we're supposed to be moving out
here
rather than backing up and saying well
she'll be invalid politics we should be
involved with everything
that's what salt and light is it gets
we must be engaged in reforming the
seven mountains of the culture not just
affect what is inside the church 2022
is the battles we're going to win in
order to recover ground that was taken
and in doing so the church is going to
come to a new dare i say militant level
of maturity we're taking our government
back
we're going to run for school board
we're going to run for pta we're going
to run for city council we're going to
run for county board of supervisors
the public school system has become
public enemy number one we need to
take back the education of our children
because whoever controls the textbooks
controls the future
this is a divine turnaround year when
this is overturned which is at hand now
we are going to see the
really a third great awakening signs
wonders and miracles
repentance
sweeping across this nation
god's raising up an awakening voice in
america and the awakening is civic as
well as spiritual
i see california awakening
the wind of change is blowing the
curriculum shall be changed by my hand
says the lord for i am releasing my
anointing
that shall break
the yoke of woke the answer for america
is a revival the answer for gen z is a
revival they gotta have an encounter
with the lord we need people all over
the country to be willing to put on that
full armor of god we will fight
and the way that we will fight is
through the inbreaking of the kingdom of
god to the earth and we will consume
everything with the power of god and we
will take back this world nobody not
even the devil himself
can stop what god has planned for this
season for this hour for such a time as
this this is isaiah 60 it's time for the
glorious church of the lord jesus christ
to arise and shine like never before and
we are going to take this nation back
we are
the army of god
and we are going to take this nation
back
i think i would be optimistic because
the people who will become the leaders
of the world this next generation as
people like us the ones that are the
right answers the ones that are here
actually out there fighting the good
fight
do you feel the wings of change
that are beginning to blow across this
land
the christians that i speak to
um they all agree in theory about this
great commission and that yes it has a
civil application or civil implications
if we teach jesus to obey or we teach
you know disciples to obey all of
jesus's commands in every realm of life
it's that it's going to have an effect
and especially when we cross reference
that and pair it with paul remaining in
the station that you were in when the
lord called you
you know like governors are going to get
saved or the jailer philippian jailer is
going to get saved people in positions
of government are going to get saved and
then we're going to disciple them to
obey jesus commands as they apply in
that station which means they're going
to have to legislate god's law rather
than man's law all those kind of things
well martin we're going to have to
legislate
god's law rather than man's law which
actually means they're going to
legislate man's law rather than god's
law
unfortunately that's what it's come to
because you are deceived you are
deceived into believing
that the changed commandments
are what god wanted
and you want to obey jesus jesus said i
have not come to abolish the law not one
jot or one tittle will by any means
disappear from the law
but they have not only changed the dot
and the
and a jot but they've changed the entire
law you know what
this type of movements and all this talk
that we see now
is the same
that happened when jesus marched into
jerusalem on the ass on the donkey
everybody was looking for that savior
that were going to
take over
the
physical land again and rid them of the
yoke of the romans this is the same type
of movement it's the same type of
movement now what's interesting martin
is that many of the speakers
were actually exposed as false prophets
because they said that trump would win
the previous election now many of them
of course will say he actually did win
it
because
that horse is not dead yet
but the fact of the matter is what if he
should come back a second term and win
they will say that they are vindicated
because you will have a second term
now whether it is trump or whether it is
someone else it is totally irrelevant
could even be pence or someone like that
yeah
it wouldn't change anything because that
jesuit trained even if it's
not a republican it's a democrat again
it will also not change it because we've
got the other side but the pendulum side
just
is leaning a bit towards maybe a
republican
so that is a very interesting situation
but
modern does this fit the prophetic
picture yes is this what we would expect
that the nation
will be so riled up that they will set
up the seven mountains which is the
kingdom of god on earth
my kingdom is not of this world
said jesus he's coming to destroy this
exactly
and that is what
we have to emphasize
we are heading towards a time
where people of god are going to think
they're doing god a favor in
implementing
laws that's not actually biblical all
right now let me let me at the at the
risk of sounding harsh
say
they all condemned
the baal worship
but they're actually falling into the
trap of baal worship
that's unfortunate and that's so true
okay martin so let's look at what trump
has to say himself on some of these
issues
we are a nation that in many ways has
become a joke
but soon we will have greatness again
it was hard-working patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working patriots like you who are
going to save our country
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no summit we cannot reach
there is no challenge we cannot
there is no victory we cannot have
we will not bend
we will not break
we will not yield ever ever ever
we will never give in we will never give
up and we will never ever back down
we will never let you down as long as we
are confident and united
the tyrants we are fighting do not
stand even a little chance
because we are americans and americans
kneel to god and god alone and it is
time to start talking about greatness
for our country
[Music]
all right martin
so we are americans we kneel to god and
god alone
so it all fits into this movement
that is gaining steam
and of course you have to bring in the
other role players so the world economic
forum
that is receiving some bad press
being
the deep state or being
the mega rich or whatever they say about
them
what is this relationship with people
for example like klaus schwab let's have
a
look what is your message
meeting with the world leaders the
biggest uh most important people in the
world and we're bringing back tremendous
business in the united states and
they're all here to see i'll be making a
speech and then we'll be leaving shortly
uh but i think it's very important the
other is just a hoax it's the witch hunt
that's been going on for years
and it's frankly it's disgraceful but
we look forward to being here klaus has
done a fantastic job and again we're
meeting with the biggest companies in
the world the biggest businesses of the
world and world leaders all for the
benefit of the united states we look
forward to the meetings why not have
a right on witnesses change mr president
oh i'm a big believer in the environment
the environment to me is very important
all right so he's a big believer in the
environment klaus has done a great job
he's going to bring all the businesses
back
totally forgets that you'll own nothing
and be happy
which is totally contrary to the
american dream
but
just shows how you know two opposite
ideologies
come together and in the end find a
common ground
here's a statement from the spirit of
prophecy that is
perhaps enlightening in terms of the
times in which we are living
by the parable of the householder who
went into a far country after delivering
to his servants his goods
christ is represented
he is watching and waiting for fruit
from those to whom he has entrusted his
vineyard
but the issue is worship
the chosen people refused to be
convicted of sin
and when god sent his son they said this
is the heir come let us kill him and the
inheritance will be ours.
today the lord is looking upon his
vineyard
the walls are broken down through
transgression of his law
he sees the ingratitude of his stewards
who refuse to render to him the fruits
of his ground
god does not design that men shall
appropriate all that the earth produces
for their own selfish purposes
he calls upon them to bring their tithes
and offerings into his storehouse
that there may be meat in his house in
india china russia
and the cities of america thousands of
men and women are dying of starvation
the moneyed men because they have the
power control the markets
they purchase at low rates all they can
obtain and then sell at greatly
increased rates and prices
this means starvation to the poorer
classes and will result in a civil war
but is there enough anger out there for
a civil war
definitely this
you can see it not only in the other
nations but you see it brewing in the
united states as well okay
is it within the power of the nations to
keep the price of
oil and gasoline
at a reasonable level
well
yes
all that has to happen is the countries
of the middle east will have to increase
their production a little bit then the
war
that you have in the ukraine should be
offset by this well even
if you go and look all the major
energy companies like exxon mobil and
all of them had record profits
so if they just lower their prices
without making billions of profits
that will also
lower the price of yes and if you put
climate change into the mix and you make
sure that none of these fossil fuels are
burnt
but they're going to be burnt anyway
because you're still driving your car
then all you are doing is increasing the
anger that's it so you're stirring the
chaos
yes
so here's an interesting statement will
result in civil war is there talk of
that nature somewhere
definitely
there will be a time of trouble such as
never was since there was a nation at
that time shall michael stand up the
great prince which standeth for the
children of thy people and there shall
be a time of trouble
such as never was since there was a
nation even to that same time
now martin
when does that time come doesn't that
time come when they say
peace and safety
precisely so actually they've achieved
what they were
wanting to achieve
we're back on track
so when they say we're back on track we
have taken back the reins of power
isn't that when sudden destruction comes
yes so is there a double blind here it's
a double blind and this also shows you
the nearness of this
all right so there will be a time of
trouble such as never was since there
was a nation even to that same time and
at that time
thy people shall be delivered every one
that shall be found written in the book
now if you are going to be delivered
then what are you going to be delivered
from
this coercion operation and
what is happening all right because up
until that time
deliverance was all about sin
deliverance from sin
but here will be an actual deliverance
from physical circumstances
from legislation that threatens to kill
you the bible says so you won't be able
to by itself and then the decree will go
out that they can kill you
okay
many shall be purified and made white
and tried but the wicked shall do
wickedly and none of the wicked shall
understand but the wise shall understand
now when daniel talks about the wise
who are the wise
the people that are studying the
prophecies and adhere to biblical
commandments and here to the biblical
principles so
if you want to know about the doctrine
then keep the commandments
so what are the possibilities of these
things happening that the anger should
rise to a fever pitch and out of that
fever pitch
you eventually get the order
that is the image of the beast which
legislates on behalf of the beast which
is catholicism
and
then it is the so-called christian world
united against this antichrist who
doesn't even exist because he's already
amongst us
that's uh where the deception that's
exactly how the deception is working so
let's listen to what this man has to say
on abc news sources tell abc news
there's been a strong reaction to the
raid on extremist and q anon related
forums sources say there's been a strong
reaction to the raid on extremists and q
anon related forums sources also telling
abc news there's been a strong reaction
from some extreme groups online
including q anon and other groups
there's been a strong reaction to the
raid on extremists and q and un-related
forums including those that were active
before january 6. including those that
were active prior to january 6th
including those that were active prior
to january 6 involved in the january 6
insurrections including those that were
active prior to the january 6 riot some
have been calling for violence and even
a civil war some of them include cults
for violence and even a civil war some
of them include calls for violence and
online forms and even civil war this was
the top comment on the search on the
pro-trump site the donald last night
quote lock and load with references to a
civil war talking very violently about
civil war searches for civil war
spikes they're talking about civil war
civil war silver war civil war civil war
civil war this is the kind of violence
that led to the january 6th attack
martin
is that
repetitive
propaganda definitely
is that
in line with what we just read just now
it's in line with what we read we've
also seen the effect of this type of
propaganda in the last few years and so
the pendulum i believe is going to swing
no matter who the role players are
that's irrelevant but the pendulum is
going to swing
and there will
be an image to the beast that will be
set up the same
power
of church and state united
enforcing
a morality which they call biblical but
which is everything but
biblical
so
the evening news 30 july 2022
iceland shoppers demand law change as
supermarket makes major announcement
manchester evening news shared the news
on social media and the response was
overwhelming while many praised iceland
for the decision most people saw it as
an opportunity
to demand the law change to allow
supermarkets to close on sunday
martin we're putting these in to show
that there is this driving force behind
the scenes
for particularly
one moral stature that they want
introduced as legislation
that's exactly what's happening is it a
popular call yes
is aren't we told in the spirit of
prophecy that it will be because of the
clamoring of the people that this
legislation will be introduced exactly
now who puts it into the minds of the
people so that they can start clamoring
propaganda propaganda
this is amazing
okay angela jackson said don't open on a
sunday end off we used to manage and i'm
sure we'd manage again give staff a day
of rest gin right exclaimed good should
not
shop on sundays you have six days to
shop rest on the seventh
they're so confused because that's not
the seventh it's the first
fairy breakdowns the rebuke from god for
sailing on the sabbath
so this is god's displeasure after the
introduction of sunday sailing to the
western isles of scotland the reverend
david blunt
clerk of the free church continuing of
scotland's north
east and grimsey presbytery on the
island said an analysis of mechanical
failures in the calmac's fleet showed a
remarkable difference between the
breakdowns before and after sabbath
sailing started in 2009
this is
pure propaganda it has no basis
whatsoever he's even got the day wrong
you remember when the catholic church
used to put out stories of miracles
that happened on
this according to them the sabbath but
on sundays yes to promote it
and we have the same happening today
again the weeping statues all of these
things this is all to create a hype
that's it now you've got fleets that's
breaking down because you're breaking
the sabbath according to them
okay what is sunday reset on tick tock
the sunday reset trend on tick tock is
practically a movement
it even has an official tagline gas
prices are likely to continue climbing
through 2022
here's how to save at the pump so let's
see what their solution is
when you search the hatch tag on the app
the first thing you'll notice is that it
has over a whopping 447 million views
it also has a description unlike other
organic hashtags on the platform whether
you're cleaning the house or putting
your feet up it's time for a sunday
reset
is it is it a movement yes and it's like
we've mentioned you must see this it's
drawn from
religious angles and from secular
because they're using climate change and
all of these so this is this
now the bible clearly says that the
beast out of the earth will lead out
and the whole world will follow
so in other words it has to be
a global issue
and that means you have to tie something
secular to the religious and climate
change is the most obvious at the moment
so in cultures around the world
especially in the us sundays are
preserved for winding down prepping for
the week resting up and observing any
spiritual practices on tick-tock
people are sharing their sunday reset
routines as inspiration and as asmr
these relaxing wellness videos make
doing your chores looks satisfying but
they also turn what's necessary and
tedious into a more unified experience
is there a mass movement to condition
humanity in a direction oh for sure who
controls these medias mod
where did they all go and visit it went
all back to the vatican
indian express sunday reset to start the
week
so is it a global issue
definitely as a hindu nation right
a declared hindu nation
monday morning blues enter the
prescription the sunday rest tik tok the
world's biggest trend recorder and
unfortunately band in india is bustling
with the sunday recep concept
with over a billion hits thousands of
tweets facebook posts instagram videos
it is the internet rage of the day
so what's the sunday reset before
heading out to face another stressful
week it is necessary to slow down
empty your physical and mental space by
creating a calm physical environment
around you you also create calm within
numerous past studies have shown the
value of decluttering life
does indian philosophy and yoga and all
of that fit into this perfectly i mean
that create a calm within you've got
buddhism even inside of this and all of
us everything is there a 2011 study
by the journal of neuroscience concluded
that clutter prevents the brain from
focusing so what we should defragment
well god gave us a day for that
yes
and leaves a person with a worry at the
back of their mind that there is
something they have forgotten to do the
sunday reset seems to be the solution
martin this is all very current how can
people say there's no movement the
problem is because people agree with
this because the bible says that you
have to rest on the seventh day the
problem is they've got the wrong day
but if they have the wrong day
they have the wrong authority that is
that
the whole point that's the point it's
not the day that's the issue it's
coupled to it yeah it's the authority
who
has the say
so let's just remind the viewers that we
are dealing with biblical prophecy we've
had these verses on the screen
so many times let's read them again
and deceive us
we don't have to go much further right
no
that's exactly what all of this is about
and deceiveth them that dwell on the
earth by the means of these miracles
which he had power to do in the sight of
the beast did you see those mega
movements with
all the hands praying i mean my heart
goes out to them but
they have a wrong issue
saying to them that dwell on the earth
that they should make an image to the
beast which had the wound by the sword
and did live
roman catholicism received the mortal
wound when its political power was taken
away in 1798.
that power was partially restored in
1929 when the vatican again became a
political entity
but it didn't have international clout
now it is not only welcomed in
the legislatures of the united states
but it is the spokesperson
and the leading figure of the united
nations
and it has actually become part of the
political realm of the united nations
yes
it actually had its accession
which means it's taking over the kingly
role again
so
they are going to revive
the image of the beast and this
movements that we've just seen all this
talk the the the these people show you
that they are healing the wound
completely they are healing it
completely
and he had power to give life unto the
image of the beast so it's going to come
to fruition it's going to happen
that the image of the beast should both
speak and cause
that means it has legislative power
that means they will come to power
and cause what that as many as would not
worship the image of the beast should be
killed
the bible says do you not know that whom
you obey
you are servant to
if that person said
you will live under christian laws
so if you don't want to adhere to that
law
you will be killed or you will be set
out correct
and the third angel followed them saying
with a loud voice if any man worship the
beast and his image and receive his mark
in his forehead or in his hand the same
shall drink of the wine of the wrath of
god which is poured out without mixture
into the cup of his indignation
so you have a contrast
you have the world saying we'll do it
and you have god saying if you do it
i will pour out my wrath without
mercy
and he shall be tormented with fire and
brimstone in the presence of the holy
angels and in the presence of the lamb
so god will destroy them
by fire
so martin he has the choice
and the world is
running into the trap
may god give us
wisdom
and
i wish we could
somehow
state it in a way that everybody
would get the picture we are in the most
serious time
that the world has ever been in in its
history
let's pray definitely
heavenly
father
all of these things are coming to
fruition
thy word is a lamp unto our feet
without it we would be lost in a sea of
confusion
lord open the eyes of your people you
have tried
you gave them the reformation
you told them who the antichrist was you
separated the churches
is it your fault that they have
realigned themselves
error and truth come together
surely not
is this warning that you are giving
warranted no it is an appeal a final
appeal to humanity
help many to heed it in jesus name i
pray amen amen
[Music]
you